ja harter cut aber ich bin enttäuscht
dass ich überhaupt über dieses Thema
sprechen muss und zwar geht es mir
hauptsächlich darum dass wir uns jeden
Tag über Kosten von Energie Strom und
Gas unterhalten und vergessen dabei die
wichtigste Energie überhaupt die
Landwirte hunderttausende noch 200.000
knapp in Deutschland jeden Tag für uns
produzieren aus Sonne Erde und ein
unfassbaren Know-how und uns jeden Tag
versorgen und genau das steht auf dem
Spiel
Europa aber auch Deutschland forciert
immer mehr Abkommen mit Ländern wie
Südamerika das Merkur so Abkommen oder
ceta Abkommen was jetzt neulich erst
beschlossen wurde mit Kanada wir
importieren Ware die nicht ansatzweise
unsere Standards hat und wir reden den
ganzen Tag von Klimaschutz Artenschutz
wir reden von Kreislaufwirtschaft und
aus Gegenteil passiert jeden Tag sterben
in Deutschland 10 Höfe und die kommen
niemals wieder und wir haben nichts
gelernt aus der Abhängigkeit zum
Beispiel aus Russland weil wenn diese
Energiequellen also
Erfahrung die wir zu uns nehmen nicht
mehr zu uns herkommen kann haben wir
einen massives Problem und was bedeutet
das wenn man das jetzt wirklich
zusammenfasst für unser Land naja dass
wir uns wieder mal in einer Abhängigkeit
begeben von Ländern wir haben gerade
über autokarten gesprochen gucken Sie
mal wie viele wie viele Ware hier aus
China kommt wir importieren Ware im Wert
von 90 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr aus 173
Ländern und das war 1990 nicht so 1990
hatten wir 100% Autarkie da konnten wir
zu 100% selbst versorgen wir haben ein
Selbstversorgungsgrad aktuell von
Gemüse und Obst von gerade mal 30
Prozent wir hatten vor drei Jahren bei
Weizen ein Selbstversorgungsgrad von
110%. das wird von der politischen Seite
kritisiert dass wir damit zu viel haben
also man muss auch froh sein dass man
eine reservt von einem Prozent das sehr
lächerlich und wir sehen es jetzt also
zugespitzt wir können uns nicht mehr
selbst ernähren also wir werden uns wir
könnten uns selbst ernähren wenn wir
politischen
Rückendeckung hätten man würde uns die
Handfesseln lösen weil das unehrlich und
die Doppelmoral an der ganzen Nummer ist
ja dass wir hier
tierwohlstandards die vollkommen zurecht
eingeführt werden dass wir hier keine
falsch versteht nur diese Standards
diese Sozialstaates sind 12 Euro
Mindestlohn oder die Umweltstandards die
wir zurecht haben die hat doch nicht
Einsatzweise jemand in Südamerika in
China oder in Australien die EU hat
einen Abkommen mit Australien gerade
beschlossen die ich Australien haben
gesagt wir werden eure Standard sich
erfüllen können das machen wir auch
nicht da die EU trotzdem gesagt dann
unterschreiben aber trotzdem
Lösungsansatz die Lösungsansatz ist ja
dass wir erstmal sagen wir importieren
nur Ware die auch unsere Standards hat
das ist doch beim Auto vollkommen normal
wenn der Japaner der Amerikaner ein Auto
importiert dann muss das die Standards
haben die unsere
Straßenverkehrszulassungsordnung zu sie
ist zulässt und nichts anderes oder wenn
ich einen Stecker importier aus China
hat er ein CE-Siegel wir importieren wie
teurer wird das für ein Verbraucher
werden also wie viel mehr würde es mich
dann kosten weil grundsätzlich glaube
ich ganz sicher das sagt ja sogar
erhältst sie mir da hat er sogar jetzt
quasi mal recht das ist im im
mittelfristigen Bereich günstiger wird
und wir müssen uns aber auch davon
wegmachen nur weil es ein Cent günstiger
ist machen wir das wir haben ein
Oligopol mit den vier mächtigen
Lebensmittel einzeichnen die 90 Prozent
in Deutschland kontrollieren die
bestimmen erstmal was wir bekommen wir
sind das einzige Gewerk in Deutschland
was kein Preisschild an seiner Leistung
machen kann wir müssen das nehmen was
Edeka Aldi und Co uns anbietet und da
geht es um Cent-Beträge zum Beispiel
importieren wir dann Kirschen aus der
Türkei Kirschen und zwar zu Erntezeit
wenn wir hier Kirschen haben das gleiche
hatten wir bei Erdbeeren das wird ja
auch in den Medien abrichtet wir haben
Erdbeerbauern die haben die beste Ernte
hingestellt so nachhaltig wie es
irgendwie nur geht und haben die dann
abgemolzt und dann gegrobert also den
Boden bearbeitet und dann meist den
gepflanzt wir haben also mehr
essensverschwendung geht ja gar nicht
ich meine wir schmeißen pro Tag 30.000
Tonnen pro Tag in Deutschland
Lebensmittel weg aber die größte Essen
Verschwendung findet ihr auf den Feldern
statt das ist ja der Skandal einer
Nummer und da wenn wir wirklich Wache
ein waches Auge haben ansonsten wir
haben es jetzt gesehen wir haben
Abkommen mit Argentinien forciert habe
ich gerade schon erwähnt argentinien hat
jetzt nichts mehr exportiert weil die
eine Missernte hatten die haben halt
Trockenheit ohne Ende Australien
Ausgleiche Australien hatten schwere
Überschwemmung die kommen zu 80% gar
nicht auf die Felder drauf um jetzt die
sind ja jetzt bald in der Ernte das
überhaupt zu ernten und wollen wir uns
in die Abhängigkeit begeben wir haben ja
eine Politikerin am Tisch die ist jetzt
ja nicht in der Ampel sondern in der
Union CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete aber der
fragt man sich natürlich schon wenn man
Handy so zuhört wie konnte es denn also
weit kommen und was tut die deutsche
Politik jetzt um das zu verbessern also
ich muss vielleicht erstmal dazu sagen
dass ich Bundestagsabgeordnete für den
Wahlkreis Berlin-Mitte bin das ist
wahrscheinlich einer der Wahlkreise mit
dem wenigsten mit der wenigsten
landwirtschaftlichen Produktion in ganz
Deutschland deswegen ist das nicht mein
Schwerpunktthema aber ich bin mir nicht
so sicher ob ich das Argument wirklich
so hundertprozentig Teile was sie gerade
vorgetragen haben denn es mir ist jetzt
zu sehr schwarz und weiß also wir sind
ja auch innerhalb der EU wir haben
handeln mit unseren EU-Partnern mit
vielen anderen Ländern und diese
Freihandelsabkommen diese genannt haben
übrigens ceta wollen wir als cdu/csu
unbedingt auf die Tagesordnung des
Deutschen Bundestages bringen das wird
dauernd von der Ampel wieder runter
genommen denn wir versprechen uns eben
genau das das unter anderem auch diese
Standards eingehalten werden und wir
dazu einer besseren Verbindung kommen
was den Handel angeht aber fakt ist doch
dass diese Abschottung und doch gar
nicht weiter bringt denn diese
Abschottung was was ist also sie
plädieren sozusagen für 100 Prozent ich
habe gesagt wir brauchen wenn überhaupt
wahre importiert wird dieselben
Standards es kann doch nicht sein dass
wir jetzt allen Ernst aus Südamerika
vari importieren die mit
Pflanzenschutzmitteln behandelt wurde
die bei uns seit 30 Jahren verboten sind
wo es Argentinien Rindfleisch rüberkommt
was mit Wachstumshormonen gefüttert wird
was bei uns seit Jahren vollkommen zu
Recht verboten ist und dann auf Schiffe
die Beschwerden hier überfahren und die
fleischware dort Tiefkühl gelagert ist
es genau so schwachsinnig wie LNG Gas
aus den USA hat dafür sind doch diese
Freihandelsabkommen da dass man sich
darüber verständigt was sind die
Standards ja was machen Sie hier nicht
das machen sie als Politiker gar nicht
vollkommen egal ich habe sie gerade
ausgeführt die EU sagt Australien ihr
müsst Standards erfüllen wie unsere
sagen machen wir nicht trotzdem wird
unterschrieben ceta genau das gleiche
sie glauben noch nicht allen Ernstes
dass die kanadische Landwirtschaft
genauso hochmodern und genauso
professionell läuft und genauso
nachhaltig wie bei uns das nicht ernst
also kann er da ist schon auf einem sehr
hohen Standard das sehr hohen Ausrede
stellen aber ttip gerade bei ttip als
die Diskussion doch wahr haben wir doch
über chlorhühnchen und so weiter
gesprochen da ging es um Standards
deswegen dieses Argument das dem das
teile ich nicht
Teil der Teil der Meinung weil wir sind
ja in die Garage ich bin jetzt hier
selbst CDU-Mitglied aber wir sind ja
auch durch die CDU genau da reingekommen
weil man bewusst irgendwie hier bei uns
ein bullerbüh haben will bei uns muss
alles alte schönen Sonnenschein sein was
woanders auf der Welt passiert ist
vollkommen egal das hat übrigens Schüler
Klöckner uns hier in Berlin gesagt
fakt ist ja spannend Märkte
funktionieren ja nach Angebot und
Nachfrage eigentlich in jedem Bereich
dementsprechend nehmen Sie mir die Frage
nicht übel aber wenn diese Produkte so
viel besser sind warum dann kauft der
Konsument nicht einfach lieber die
Produkte aus Deutschland das kann ich
ihm sagen am Regal endet die Moral dann
müssen wir uns auch mal ehrlich machen
als Bürger das ist nun mal so aber
trotzdem versuchen Sie mal nur als
Beispiel in Supermarkt zu gehen und ein
deutschen Apfel zu finden selbst wenn
sie dann Bio gucken kaufen wollen da
finden sie bioöpfel die kommen aus aus
Peru aus Neuseeland und aus Südafrika
was soll denn daran Bio sein die meiste
Obst und Gemüse etwas bio ist kommt
übrigens aus Spanien was unter
Plastikfolie hergestellt wird Millionär
100.000 hunderte von Hektaren sieht man
aus dem Weltall übrigens und das wird
nur von deutschen Markt aber weil die
Deutschen Äpfel teurer sind oder warum
wahrscheinlich sind die ein bisschen
teurer das mag sein aber ich meine ich
gehe jeden Tag einkaufen mit meinen
Kindern also nicht jeden Tag aber jeden
Samstag auf jeden Fall hatte mir frei
und ich gucke mir bewusst die ganzen
Preise an es ist ja auch unheimlich
schwer und das ist ja was wir von Anfang
an gefordert wir brauchen eine klare
unmissverständliche
Herkunftskennzeichnung der Produkte dass
jeder Bürger hingehen kann sagt okay das
ist doch da und daher das hat die und
die Standards das kaufe ich kaufe ich
nicht wir fragen einmal in der Runde
Herr Ralf achten Sie darauf wo die
Produkte herkommen die Sie einkaufen
nein ich habe ich achte auf eine
Qualität und ich habe irgendwann mal
begriffen das eine Flasche Wein nicht
unter 5 € Kosten kann meine Schwägerin
ist Winzerin und die hat mal gesagt komm
doch mal mit hoch hilfe mein heb mal ein
bisschen so ein Tag nach einer Stunde
habe ich gesagt alle Tassen im Schrank
bei mir kommt der Wein aus der Flasche
danke schön aber da habe ich verstanden
das geht nicht Fleisch Menschen wollen
das ist der da vielleicht wer der Ansatz
nur das mit euch gefühlt Moment nicht
helfen aber das verbrauche irgendwann
mal begreifen müssen ein Stück Fleisch
das eine Qualität haben soll wie ich sie
meinen Kindern gerne anbiete und mir
auch geht nicht unter einem bestimmten
Preis und wenn es dann andere Anbieter
gibt das ist die Koks der freien
Marktwirtschaft und wenn du kein
Protektionismus machen willst wenn du
den alles zu macht dann könnten wir es
würden wir Sie aber auch die gleichen
Standards da sind sie auch meiner
Meinung bin ich da bin natürlich gute
Standards und hohe Standards haben
sollten das doch ganz klar im Übrigen
gehe ich auch damit wenn sie sagen wir
müssen die deutsche Landwirtschaft
Stärken ganz klar natürlich aber es
passiert nicht sie können mir glauben
genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall warum
machen denn zehn Betriebe jeden Tag zu
in Deutschland kann nicht sein das ist
doch unfassbar und also sehen Sie denn
nur die Schuld in der Politik na die
Rahmenbedingungen sind von der Politik
gesetzt worden da vollkommen klar
selbstverständlich wir haben und gerade
aktuell ist es so dass natürlich auch
diejenigen die auch gerade Fleisch
einkaufen müssen auch ehrlich weil sagen
die bei uns zu schlachten wir kriegen
momentan die absolute Mehrheit an
Schweinen aus Spanien und aus Dänemark
ist auch es hat mir die Regionalität und
mit Nachhaltigkeit ja gar nichts zu tun
aber wir wollen uns ja auch nicht
komplett abschotten angesprochen aber
wir können uns hier mit sicherlich eine
Runde alle auf dieselben Standards ein
aber das passiert nun mal auch nicht und
das ist einfach unehrlich und der Bürger
weiß es nicht aber kann es auch gar
nicht wissen deswegen eine echte
Herkunftskennzeichnung wie ist das
behandelt worden hat dass jemand
Tierwohl gesehen dass es jemals
Umweltstandards und Sozialstandards
gesehen das muss doch hier eine Runde
eigentlich jeder verstehen und das
eigentlich mit den Energiekosten gerade
um jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen
anderes Thema reinzuwerfen aber das wäre
mir auch noch mal wichtig zu finden
genau so wie jeden anderen draußen jeden
anderen im Mittelstand es ist gar nicht
tragbar die Milchbauern kriegen aktuell
60 Cent da hätten wir vor zwei Jahren
Luftsprünge gemacht aber trotzdem ist ja
alles andere viel viel teurer geworden
ja aber auch
nehmen Sie zum Beispiel wenn Sie Lego
Batterien haben Strom oder halt Gas
brauchen Sie natürlich als als Wärme für
Schweineställe oder so es ist nicht
bezahlbar und das ist eigentlich
momentan das Problem und andere haben
ein völlig ein Wettbewerbsvorteil in der
EU schon mal weil wir auch in der TU
dieselben Standards haben das gehört
soweit natürlich auch dazu aber
natürlich auch von Übersee also der
selbst der Chinese der der baut ja
gerade 12 24 stöckige Hochhäuser weil
die so ein Haarfarben an an Essen also
50 Prozent des globalen Getreides der
Reserve liegt übrigens in China und die
kaufen gerade alles leer alle Märkte und
das ist das was ich sage wenn wir
irgendwann mal abhängig sind von anderen
Ländern und die sagen Brazil first
Australia first dann gucken wir in die
Röhre
wenn man aber als erstes Land anfängt
dann macht jeder irgendwann diese
nationalistische Haltung aber ich
verstehe was sie meinen ich finde stark
dass sie dieses platzt
haben wir können wir gerne auf eine
Märkte aber die gleichen Standards also
die gleichen Standards für alle Länder
wo es eingeführt